you didn't cite any evidence  to to talk about the climate change i  said that the the uh mankind is not  going to be wiped out within 20 years  because no scientist seriously i'm sorry  science would disagree uh which  scientist the uh the 97 of all  scientists who say that one to two  degrees celsius  will melt the ice caps  such that there will be rising sea  levels mass extinctions and it won't end  the earth but it will change to a  certain point the ecology of our planet  such that it is much more difficult for  humans to survive that is the consensus  and a lot of climate change deniers like  yourself like ben like clavin they they  perpetuate that this is all a liberal  hoax and that and that science i'm not  saying it's a liberal i mean it's  obviously being pushed by politicians  primarily that's why at the united  nations it's not politics  politicians are going to push political  issues right it's politics not science  that's my point